[Musica]
una sera una sera a tutti sarò molto
Franco con voi non sono uno speaker
professionale Non sono un youtuber un
blogger quindi le mie capacità
comunicative a volte sono un po' flebili
avrò bisogno di tutto il vostro aiuto
per condividere con voi quella che alla
fine è la mia esperienza sono più un
uomo diciamo del fare che un
comunicatore per fare questo è
necessario che mi seguiate un attimo
è necessario che provate a fare un
viaggio con me e questo viaggio inizia a
Belluno
fuori fa caldo
Siamo in estate e ovviamente arriva il
momento dei centri estivi i bambini
devono prepararsi per andare al centro
estivo quindi braghe corte
zainetti in spalla cappellino tutta la
felicità di rivedere gli amici e
riuscire a passare una giornata intera a
giocare a discutere se discutere si può
dire ma sicuramente a scambiare idee e a
parlare fra di loro Quindi partiamo da
qua cerchiamo di focalizzarci su questa
scena
Poi d'estate passa
arriva l'autunno e dopo il periodo
estivo si torna a scuola
si torna a scuola e di nuovo c'è la
stessa preparazione c'è un po' di
emozione no si ci ricordiamo tutti
quando eravamo piccoli torna alla scuola
voleva dire il momento in cui si
riscontrava gli amici voleva dire un po'
di ansia perché almeno io non si erano
fatti i compiti per le vacanze non
adeguatamente quantomeno e quindi di
nuovo abbiamo il cappellino lo zainetto
i pantaloni sono diventati lunghi fa più
freddo e immaginiamo questa scena dei
bambini che a Belluno attraversano le
strisce pedonali con voi con i fratelli
con la mamma col papà entrano a scuola
dove c'è la maestra e di rinizia l'anno
scolastico
Ecco
concentriamoci un attimo su questa scena
e dopo insieme proviamo a cominciare un
viaggio guardando questo breve video
[Musica]
siamo partiti queste foto è la prima
volta che le condivido con qualcuno ho
deciso di condividere tutte con voi
Alcune sì avevo già condivise ma non
sono foto che troverete sui giornali
sono fatto che vengono dal mio cellulare
dalle mie missioni dai miei
viaggi in Medio Oriente nordafrica e
Asia sono le foto del mio lavoro in
parte e sono le foto di altri bambini
che affrontano la quotidianità di cui
parlavamo prima Certo La situazione è un
po' diversa Ma è giusto sempre pensare
come dice il titolo che c'è qualcosa là
fuori e quindi quest'oggi seppur
rapidamente ho pensato di portarvi con
me in questo viaggio cercando anche di
descrivervi quelle che sono le foto che
avete visto
Partiamo dalla Siria questa alle mie
spalle è una foto in Siria relativamente
recente in Siria abbiamo parlando di
fenomeni migratori più di 6 milioni di
persone sfollate interne
milioni di persone che hanno abbandonato
il paese al seguito della Primavera
araba della guerra civile durata più di
10 anni Milioni di bambini che devono
andare a scuola in questa condizione
nella condizione che avete visto prima e
non stiamo parlando di un paese tanto
lontano per arrivare in Siria si vola su
Beirut in Libano sono più o meno 2000
2300 km di distanza di volo aereo Io non
sono un esperto di chilometri ma
purtroppo ormai sono un po' esperto di
ore di volo me ne sono più o meno da
Roma due ore e mezzo volo credo che da
Roma si fa per andare a Londra quindi
stiamo parlando veramente di qualcosa
vicino a noi
E questa invece spostandoci della serie
la Giordania in Giordania c'è una città
una città l'ho rinominata io così non
sono l'unico non sono originale una
città che non esisteva al confine Fra la
Siria e la Giordania 80.000 persone
facciamo una proporzione con Belluno che
ne ha più o meno 35 mila 80.000 persone
vivono ad altari un campo rifugiati
siriani il più grande campo rifugiati
siriani del mondo dove Dopo anni di vita
le persone hanno dato vita veramente una
città con tutto quello che c'è nelle
città quella che vedete sotto è la
strada principale loro le chiamano gli
champs-élysé li potete trovare negozi
potete trovare piccoli bar potete
trovare veramente tutto quello che c'è
in un'altra città ovviamente in
condizioni differenti completamente
differenti che potrete immaginare e la
cosa che ha colpito di me più di tutte
me quando ci sono state che ci sono
anche negozi di abiti da sposa ci sono
delle persone che aveva Azzari si
sposano e ci sono dei bambini che
nascono dal zatarie che non sanno cos'è
la vita fuori da lì
spostandoci in poco possiamo arrivare in
Libano il Libano è un piccolo paese ho
lavorato lì due anni ci aggiungiamo
anche i mezzi di studio un po' di più
perché ho anche studiato in divano Beh
pensate che il Libano stiamo parlando
sempre di due ore di volo eh 2 ore e
mezza massimo 3 pensate che Libano ha 5
più o meno 5 milioni di abitanti
e il numero dei rifugiati in Libano dei
solo dei rifugiati Siani è 800 mila se
aggiungiamo palestinesi racheni e altri
rifugiati raggiungiamo facilmente un
milione di persone cioè da un lato
abbiamo 5 milioni di abitanti da un lato
un sesto della popolazione un milione
sono rifugiati
e questo è uno dei primi messaggi che
volevo portare cioè quando parliamo di
emergenza migratoria in Italia Certo è
giusto affrontarla è giusto ragionarci è
giusto parlare di regolazione
dell'immigrazione Ma bisogna anche un
po' cercare di capire cosa c'è là fuori
non lontano da noi lo ripeto continuerò
a batterlo ma molto vicino a noi è
quello che è successo recentemente in
Ucraina Fra l'altro ci fa capire ancora
di più quanto sia vicino a noi Oggi
leggevo le news prima di salire sul
palco sarà una giornata che Ci
ricorderemo per quello che sta
succedendo in Siria
ma continuiamo il nostro viaggio il
nostro viaggio arriva adesso in
Bangladesh qua siamo molto più lontani
io non so se voi lo sapete ma pochi anni
fa in Myanmar sono come state le
persecuzioni in una popolazione nella
popolazione rohinga loro hanno dovuto
attraversare il confine per scappare
popolazione musulmana e sono andati
tutti a finire non tutti ma la maggior
parte a Cox Bazar
cocktail è un piccolo
quasi villaggio potremmo dire al sud del
Bangladesh Ecco quello che vedete alle
mie spalle è un'altra città nata nel
nulla nel giro di veramente pochissimi
mesi non anni mesi perché tutti quelli
che vedete sono baracche di rifugiati
rochinga a Cox Bazar
stiamo parlando di più di 800 mila
persone
Cioè questo è quello che succede e per
quello Pur non essendo un comunicatore
ho accettato l'invito perché credo che
sia giusto sempre pensare che se
vogliamo cambiare il nostro paese
abbiamo la necessità di capire cosa
succede anche all'estero e abbiamo la
necessità di provare almeno a metterci
nei panni delle altre persone Senza
nulla togliere alle difficoltà di ogni
giorno che anche noi Attraversiamo in
Italia
e l'ultima foto L'ultima foto è nel
Mediterraneo
nel Mediterraneo stanno morendo migliaia
di persone
ci sono dei calcoli che possono fare
paura Fra l'altro le nazioni unite fanno
i calcoli su i dispersi quindi non
sappiamo neanche quante persone non
abbiamo contato quando io ero su questa
nave mi ricordo abbiamo siamo
intervenuti perché eravamo a pranzo e
abbiamo visto fuori il barcone non c'era
un radar non c'era niente Abbiamo
avvistato e siamo dovuti intervenire
quindi situazioni di cui noi parliamo ma
che dobbiamo provare a capire veramente
se vogliamo cercare poi di declinare nel
giorno di ogni in ogni giorno diciamo la
motivazione al cambiamento non c'è
cambiamento secondo me il mio modesto
parere senza analizzare quello che
succede oltre la siepe e per questo
l'unico messaggio più importante che mi
sono sentita di dire è veramente Beh di
portarvi veramente Basic ed è se i
vostri figli se i vostri fratelli se i
vostri amici hanno la possibilità di
passare un periodo all'estero
spingetevi a farlo Non è facile Però
solo se noi andiamo all'estero
incontriamo altre culture cerchiamo di
capire quello che sta succedendo oltre
la sia per il tuo confine di fronte a
noi solo così riusciremo veramente
a capire come poter poi cambiare quello
che succede in Italia e vi lascio per
metterti di andare a prendere la
leggendovi un piccolo un piccolo pezzo
un piccolo pezzo di un discorso che ha
fatto pochi anni fa Sergio Marchionne
e diceva aveva ragione Cesare Pavese
quando disse che viaggiare è una
brutalità
obbliga ad avere fiducia negli stranieri
e a perdere di vista il comfort
familiare della casa degli amici ci si
sente costantemente fuori equilibrio
nulla è nostro tranne le cose essenziali
l'aria il sonno i sogni il mare il cielo
tutte le cose tendono verso l'eterno o
ciò che possiamo immaginare di esso Ma è
proprio per questo che viaggiare
cambiare ambiente e conoscere altre
culture e uno straordinario modo per
crescere e per farlo in fretta
il contatto con un mondo sconosciuto è
qualcosa che ti cambia nel profondo
perché ti costringe a contare solo sulle
tue forze e a superare i tuoi limiti
Grazie
[Musica]